when we get new Stargate which I know we
will I have faith I want to see a brand
new show based around the SGC and I want
to see The Return of Atlantis and in
this video I'm going to tell you exactly
how trust me when I say that you are
going to be incredibly happy with the
results welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
so I am doing a little series of videos
that I'm calling the SGC series I'm
going to pin a link to the playlist on
the top of the comments so please go and
check out the other videos in the series
but for this video I want to talk about
Atlantis
now I loved Atlanta series
um I thought it was not not my favorite
it's not as good as sg1 sg1's always the
daddy but I did love Stargate Atlantis
um I love the premise I loved the a lot
of the characters you know Shepard McKay
Taylor Woolsey when he came in towards
yeah all these characters I absolutely
adored and when we get a brand new
series of Stargate I really hope we see
where Atlantis is today so a friend of
the channel Harris had this brilliant
idea in another video that if Stargate
returned it should be based around
Stargate command that that could be a
hub where lots of other series hang off
so for example I've already talked about
the SGU and going out to the destiny and
saving Eli a video that actually was not
particularly popular with a lot of
people they said it was very dark
maybe that's because I killed almost the
entire crew except for Eli and the
destiny in the end of it was just seen
floating off into the darkness but I
think that kind of encapsulated the SGU
really and you know the start of that
show
in this little part I would say that and
we're going to have a little Atlantis
series now what would happen in this
series I can hear you crying well for
one I'd love to see a couple of the
regular characters come back I'd love to
see Shepherd return I'd love to see
Woolsey I'd love to see McKay obviously
and I've got to be a little bit
programmatic when I'm trying to imagine
what this series would look like I can't
just go I want everyone to come back
because actors move on they do different
things but I'm thinking the actors that
I've just mentioned like I think we'll
see Shepherd Taylor and um McKay would
100 want to return to this series I
could also logically see why they still
would be in and around Stargate Atlantis
wherever the Atlantis now is so first of
all guys get in the comments tell me
where do you think Atlantis would be now
but I think it would be still on Earth I
think other than maybe the Asgard core
Atlantis is Earth's most valuable
resource I think it would be a massive
research project we would have thousands
tens of thousands Engineers taking that
damn thing apart trying to learn
everything we could about the ancient
technology so one possibility is that
while our Engineers are searching
through every nook and cranny of the
bass that they find a zpm factoring I'm
sorry
a zero point module General the ancient
power source that you were coming from
Procter and that's now powering the
Outpost defenses I have since determined
that it generates its enormous power
from vacuum energy derived from a
self-contained region of Subspace time
that was a waste of a perfectly good
explanation oh by the way if you do like
the content please consider hitting the
join button and becoming a fully fledged
side tracker you can also go to
scient.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all of these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want or they
find out where a zpm factory is now I've
actually got a slightly different idea
because I actually want the villains in
this new SGC series of shows to be the
furlings or at least initially I have
this idea that maybe we haven't seen the
feelings before because they're actually
been banished by the Asgard or by the
Ancients and that now the Asgard of gone
they're able to return to our galaxy
so in my idea the furlings actually
capture Atlantis they appear from
nowhere with obviously extremely
advanced technology and they are able to
launch their Atlantis but why would they
come to Earth to steal an ancient city
ship so in the very first episode we
discovered actually the feelings know
where there is a zpm factory and they
need it they're trying to rebuild their
foothold within our galaxy and they need
energy but the factories were built in
two parts The Factory and then a city
ship that needs to come down and connect
with it they don't work otherwise you
need two parts of this machine I would
argue maybe that's an ancient security
measure something that if somebody
accidentally in the future found the zpm
factory they wouldn't actually be able
to build any of the incredible power
source without a city ship I've actually
got this idea that the um Atlantis comes
in you know like the beautiful shape
that line says that this sort of like
connects in with the factory like you
know um a jigsaw piece I just think that
would be a really nice shot and you know
maybe the end of the second episode of
this little mini series but obviously we
have to have half a chance of them
stopping them so I would say that maybe
McKay Shepard Taylor and I would love to
see Woolsey Robin Picard is just one of
my favorite actors in the man's a legend
I want to see him in everything
to worry about that later for now
congratulations
thanks
um we're actually stowed away aboard
Atlantis and the feelings don't know
they're there now this would be classic
Stargate how many times have we seen
that sort of episode done with steak
Stargate sg1 Stargate Atlantis
it's classic SGC right so
they're trying to figure out how to stop
the furlings now back at SG command we
could see them starting to maybe track
in Atlantis maybe they know what
Atlantis is and they are sending ships
to try to stop the furlings and to maybe
recapture Atlantis but that's going to
take a little bit of time so in the
meantime the feelings start to build
zpms now
it would take a little while for them to
get going on that McCain Shepard Taylor
Woolsey they set up a plan where they're
going to sabotage the factory and
prevent them building any more because
it's the only way they can see that they
can stop the feelings the way this
series ends for me would be that
McKay Shepard Woolsey Taylor they
somehow managed to damage or even
destroy the factory and prevent them
building any more of the zpms just as a
fleet of BC 304s and BC 305s arrive and
the furlings decide to make a run for it
overwhelmed by our immediate strength
they're just not ready to go Toe to Toe
with us just yet
now I know a lot of people will be
disappointed that because we want zpms
right and now the Factory's been
destroyed but I would say that we can't
be too powerful too quickly here and
zpms really would make us insanely
powerful within the Galaxy
but we could get a few zpms you know
maybe the furlings get of some and go
through the gate with a few so they've
got a few zpms that we're now really
worried about them having but at the
same time maybe we've got a few and that
allows us to you know power a few
ancient Technologies including properly
powering the Atlantis I think this would
be a really exciting series I'd love to
see some of the special effects this
series were involving I like the BC 304s
and 305s arriving maybe Atlantis now
that it's got a couple of zpms plugged
in actually does fight back initially
until Shepherd McKay Woolsey actually
trigger their plan and there's not
multiple explosions as the um Factory
gets damaged maybe that damages Atlantis
a little bit and so on and before the
feelings decide to leg it I just think
this would be a very cool battle scene
that I would die to see but guys get
into the comments tell me what you think
about my little idea about bringing back
Atlantis and bring bringing back the
furlings which I actually think for the
this little SGC series might be the
first time we see them or the first time
at very least we realize exactly who
they are or get in the comments and tell
me if you've got any other ideas about
how you would like to see Atlantis or
any things that you think could be
better in my plan I'd love to know
exactly what you think get in there and
write those very long comments that the
real fans always do
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you enjoy the content don't forget to
hit that join button because that really
supports a channel as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]